les images parlent d'elles mêmes un
paysage de destructions et de désolation
ce sont les vents jusqu'à 240 kilomètres
à l'heure qui semble avoir fait le plus
de dommages lors du passage de l'ouragan
laura le nettoyage est déjà entamée mais
les déplacements sont complexes qui a
beaucoup beaucoup de corps autour de
chemin sur les chemins d'aider des
poteaux d'électricité qui sont un peu
partout les pluies diluviennes ont aussi
causé des inondations dans plusieurs
villes côtières étant donnée la pandémie
les vastes refuge abritant des milliers
de sinistrés ne sont pas une option en
ce moment dommage collatéral de
l'ouragan laura un violent incendie a
éclaté dans une usine de produits
chimiques
les résidents des villes aux alentours
ont été sommés de fermer leurs fenêtres
et leurs appareils de climatisation pour
éviter d'inhaler des émanations toxiques
l'ouragan laura sera aussi parvenu à
déboulonner la controversée statut de
général confédéré de passage à l'agencé
fédérale des situations d'urgence
le président trump promet de se rendre
dans les états les plus éprouvés cette
fin de semaine afin de constater
l'ampleur des dégâts ici julie aimant
radio canada montréal